des rafales de plus de 100
kilomètres/heure un refroidissement
éolien à -30 et des accumulations de
neige entre 30 et 50 cm c'est ce qui
s'est abattue sur l'est du québec ces
deux derniers jours sur la côte nord la
tempête a laissé des centaines de foyers
sans électricité pendant plusieurs
heures
du jamais vu selon plusieurs résidents
de baie comeau
je préfère ce genre d'annoncé telle
quelle manne est assez exceptionnel
comme tahiti et des îles
on retrouve effectivement notre corps
mort avec un bon pied de match de
l'autre côté du fleuve en gaspésie et au
bas-saint-laurent
les conditions routières restent
difficiles ce soir notamment sur
plusieurs tronçons de la route 130 la
traverse matane baie comeau godbout a
été annulé celle de tadoussac baie
sainte catherine a repris en fin de
journée des services de garde et
d'urgence ont aussi fermé leurs portes
pour la journée ainsi que le 6 du bas
saint laurent qui a arrêté certaines de
ses activités
la tempête se déplace maintenant vers
les maritimes
la grc demande aux automobilistes de ne
pas prendre la route dans certains
secteurs
ici et zoé bellehumeur radio canada baie
comeau